stop hey are you a fan of deadpool you
like the metahumor you like how he knows
he's in comics or he's in movies or
whatever else hey little thing for you
just so you know she hulk did it first
this is the cover of the first issue of
sensational she-hulk from 1989 where she
tells the potential buyer that if they
don't buy this book she's going to come
over and rip up all your x-men comics
unless you think that was a throwaway
cover gag here is she-hulk getting
pissed off at writer and artist john
byrne when she realized the person who
she thought was going to be the new love
interest for her is already married and
also you'll notice weezy who shows her
how to cross between panels wheezy is
actually a whole thing i could go off on
her in a whole separate video but that's
not this one there's all kinds of things
like little notes left between the
editor and the artist and the inker and
all these things and as you've seen she
goes off on burn and some of the other
stuff and calls out the tropes as they
happen but here's one i really love if
you're wondering what's on the other
side as she tears open the page that's
the ad that's on the other side and when
you turn the page that was the actual ad